it may not be pretty but the area is
lively and cosmopolitan
the parisian suburb of sarcelle is home
to thousands of jews and muslims
it was once lauded as a model of how the
two religious groups could coexist in
peace
but the current conflict in gaza has
changed that
now riots dominate the streets
pro-palestinian muslim youths are
stirring up sentiment against jews
suddenly there is violence hatred and
fear in sarcelle
old people and children stay inside
women can't go out on the street alone
people are scared there's a reign of
fear
about 20 to 30 supposedly have got hold
of weapons since the demonstrations
ever since the rioters came here
not so much to destroy things but just
to beat up the jews
in late july pro-gaza protesters stormed
a jewish neighborhood they looted stores
and shouted anti-israeli slogans
the conflagration in the mideast has
also engulfed this town on the outskirts
of paris
people in sociel are shocked by the
situation
and leaders in the muslim community are
trying to restore harmony
we are absolutely shocked by what's
happened and we apologize
we apologize in the name of all muslims
local imams wrote a letter to the jewish
community
the out of control individuals who
committed these medieval acts of
violence do not belong to us
they live on the edge of society and
have neither heart nor faith
the letter is a sign of reconciliation
but the imams know that diffusing the
explosive situation is not entirely in
the hands of the muslims
anti-semitism is on the rise in france
it's become almost socially acceptable
even before the gaza conflict
politicians from the far-right front
national were stirring up hostility
toward jews says writer marek altair
what i'm afraid of is that there will
soon be a strategic alliance between the
front
and what are called jihadists or muslim
extremists
if the crisis continues to worsen
and if these two groups
the old anti-semites and the new ones
joined forces
it will be extremely dangerous for jews
in france
the left-leaning french government seems
to have underestimated the explosive
situation
alternately advocating toughness and
de-escalation
but that has been ineffectual against
anti-semitic writing
most of the demonstrators came to
sarcelle from other areas of paris
police were unprepared
that has led to an official call for the
town to have its own security zone
there is fear that the unique
multicultural life of the municipality
will be lost
the biggest group immigrated to saucell
in the 1960s when algeria gained
independence and they had to leave
there was a great deal of building to
accommodate them
as a result there are many jews as well
as muslims from the
despite their common roots the offensive
in gaza has divided the people here
the jews are concerned about their
relatives in israel
the muslims feel solidarity with the
palestinians in the gaza strip
like everybody else is
it's just too much
they're civilians women and children are
being killed it's not possible i've
never seen anything like it
the jewish community fears the next wave
of attacks the synagogue is effectively
barricaded
we only get in accompanied by author
marek alter who delivered the letter
from the muslim clerics
i think that they're sincere and that
they share our opinions but
unfortunately that isn't enough in the
current situation
they're too few that's the problem
normally there should be a big
demonstration of all muslims against
extremism but that's not happening
even moderate muslims face criticism for
doing too little to stop the violence in
society
but the muslim community also sees
itself as victimized
we can't go out onto the streets alone
anymore
people point the finger at us with this
old cliche they're the ones who
destroyed everything here
who did this in sarcelle what's this
about sarcelle we're all born in
sarcello
but the mood in cercel and throughout
the country has changed
more and more jews are unwilling to stay
in france
a record number is expected to leave the
country this year
if things keep on like this and don't
improve lots and lots of people will
move
it's the same for me
few here except for extremists want a
mass exodus of jews
most residents want sarcelle to be what
it was a lively cosmopolitan community
on the outskirts of paris